hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to how was
your weekend good ours involved a
meteorite crashing into Earth we went to
inspect it emitted a radioactive beam of
death consuming every molecule of our
audience
soon we discovered it gave us super
abilities we never had before as weird
science II beams do I could summon
explosions at will
tamra develop superhuman strength and
Malcolm had the ability to turn anything
into a video game character with these
new abilities we gave ourselves new
identities the pixel later the clubber
Rimmer
sparky-sparky boom man
together we are the adequately
impressive three and with our newfound
abilities we know exactly what we need
to do sit around and watch daredevil on
Netflix uh don't you think you should do
something with your abilities we are I'm
touching my abilities right now oh I can
do that but don't you feel you have a
responsibility to these powers it's cool
babe malcomson whoring us out to the
press just a brief reminder we're still
amazing even though we've done very
little with our amazingness Malcolm how
do you respond to people saying that
your powers are nothing but a cheap the
Bach of the new Adam Sandler movie oh
well but don't you feel like you should
be doing something important now a
Fantastic Four has taught us anything is
that we don't need to
what is it about the Fantastic Four that
can't catch a break in terms of movies I
mean granted the new one hasn't come out
yet but it's gonna suck it really is
probably very much I mean all right
anything's possible but if it's anything
like this incarnation you shouldn't be
too hopeful this film is poorly written
poorly executed and worst of all this
little to no superheroing in it they
mostly just sit around be jackasses and
admire how cool their powers are so I
figure we do the same you know just
because a multi-million dollar film did
it doesn't mean you should do it he's
right we should just sit here on our fat
asses we should sit here on our fat
asses and review this tinker cop welcome
Pentax before nah-uh in a second
hey hey hey pull something for the lady
oh the film starts off with two
scientists named Reed and been played by
young Griffin and Michael Chiklis who
wish to get funding to study a cosmic
storm that could change the way we look
at DNA they're one problem they're
asking a guy named doom yeah that's
really his name Victor Von Doom which
translates out to Victor of doom I mean
okay a rose by any other name but that
fucking name is doom same old rate
always stretching reaching for the stars
but hey don't let his label tip you off
let the giant menacing statue hiding in
the shadows during meetings and the fact
that he stole your former girlfriend tip
you off seriously his name is bond dome
this isn't gonna be a problem oh not at
all Jessica Alba plays Susan storm the
director of genetic research I'm sorry I
couldn't kiss with that without laughing
I'm surprised I made it that far I'll
sign over a fair percentage of any
applications number seventy-five 25% of
a billion is enough to get the lights on
for a while isn't it no excuse me I was
just riding in my Bowser's dungeon
elevator courtesy of the not criminal
genius who stole my girlfriend
his name is Dom as far as crew I was
hoping been good
so they all had to train to be
astronauts better get started on those
years and years or minutes and minutes
of training a few days in space it'll be
great what's the worst that can happen
did did everyone just forget that space
is space remember my brother Johnny but
it's okay as long as they have a
determined pilot on their hand sir
fucking beautiful obviously not
qualified specimen number five Johnny
played by Chris Evans you meet me at 401
at the top of the mountain this is yours
that's why I'm sorry how the fuck does
choosing the crew for this work again
too ugly
hmm ah two average two balls two Wiggly
too normal
wait what about these guys these are the
people we need to be getting into space
but those are just Glamour magazine your
perfect call them immediately rates
except for this one it's research
and by the way yeah it is strange that
Chris Evans is playing a Marvel
superhero when he's also playing one in
Captain America but honestly I always
just assumed this was Loki in disguise
yet damn it they are pretty similar I
don't know whether I should be flying or
doing Swan Lake in these suits I mean
who the hell came up with these Victor
did
oh I'm sure Victor did sure he told you
it was for advanced breasts ick ulation
research Wow
fantastic material away from
self-regulating unstable molecules as a
director of genetic research I'm very
insulted you didn't notice my rack so
they go to their space station that
honest to god is making Austin Powers
look credible as her own dr. evil and
seven of fine are having a moment
this isn't every man dreams made a woman
he can give the world
Wow I'm only mildly amused by this
Victor I have worked the cloud is
accelerating we've got minutes until it
hits not ours that storm is deadly we
need to abort get a grip Reed we didn't
come all this way to lose our nerve at
the first glitch that is to say you
didn't I apparently came here to blow a
billion dollar proposal on a woman who
doesn't even find the universe
interesting now if you'll excuse me
there's a bucket about to be filled with
my tears waiting for me
threshold in t-minus nine minutes so
what they apparently had the technology
to know years in advance what's coming
so that we can only tell them nine
minutes ahead of time that it showed up
early but hey that billion-dollar
technology isn't anything compared to
just looking to the fucking left hey not
arranging your flowers yet egghead bad
turn around but what that giant flaming
death Ghalib wah wah wah wah yeah
don't know how I miss that
this is our attempt at trying to make
sense of our power we're not buying it
either they get back to earth at first
only noticing the slightest of
differences like in the Grand potluck oh
yeah
side effects may include slight white
hair and terrifyingly inhuman stretching
but hey Alisha now look 120 if closer to
how the original characters supposed to
walk how's she doing
stable and her vitals are strong
unfortunately we couldn't do anything
about her acting but they eventually
find out that superpowers are starting
to emerge but only during situation
fitting dialogue nice to be seen oh
you're hot right thank you sure you
can't and he was frozen too nice and
thought out years later come on I'm
trying to tie them together somehow Reid
also discovers he can turn his hand into
woody the Cowboys hand boy these effects
do not age well we discover also that
Ben has gone through a really bad
transformation but it's all good because
they operate on Ninja Turtle logic so a
trenchcoat ahead apparently covers it
all up
dad it's me it's still me who's the
accident love Explorer yeah I'm pressing
charges I'll counter you being a pop
rock oh yeah few days of space it'll be
great
what's the worst that could happen okay
will you stop acting like space is a
fucking road trip it's goddamn space but
it looks like a man that's about to
commit suicide or right next to it what
are the odds
the fantastic for bringing peace and
harmony wherever they go
yeah and the Man of Steel saved
metropolis and in yet another
coincidence the rest of the team happens
to be right on the bridge we're not
gonna get past these guys but you could
oh really because I think we could just
tell them that we know the guy you need
to strip couldn't you just stretch over
them rather easily you need to strip
they can clearly see what I'm doing I
don't even think you do but strip your
half Aiken and everything else you do
just fucking strong oh god I thought we
were Marvel in that DC but whoops I
guess her powers stop I'm gonna got to
wear underwear oh man I haven't seen a
more appropriate usage of underwear
since star trek into darkness no really
the movie would fall apart without it
Jesus Christ this is the most
accident-prone bridge I've ever seen
what doesn't cause an emergency on this
thing
but the for them of course managed to
save get down on the ground get down on
the ground now
well the crowd seems to like him so what
the hey your popularity equals no
arrests today what Ben's fiancee doesn't
seem to agree I don't care if you saved
a dozen people you look like a decaying
uber Lula in my book that's bad that's
what they're calling the Fantastic
Four's
you believe this which one of you sit
leave what but who would ask that which
one of yous the leaf I'm just assuming
that all good Samaritans have leaders
I'm also gonna be a copy of your themes
off so they seclude themselves in the
building to discover more about their
powers welcome back to the Baxter dr.
Richards I've got the usually for you
good to have you back sir okay I'm so
The Watcher so we spend the majority of
their times figuring out how to control
their new abilities any hotter and
you're approaching supernova suite not
only could you kill yourself but you
could set fire to Earth's atmosphere and
destroy human life as we know it okay
important safety tip thank you we got
you should be able to bend light around
other objects eating people if you could
control the emotional state better Wow a
person whose powers is tied to their
emotion I have never friggin seen that I
mean you broke up with me right I was
ready for the next step you were I think
there's a little bit more complicated
than that
I just wanted to share an apartment what
was so complicated about that uh-huh
we're men we just don't do the
commitment thing remember any cheese's
if Jessica Alba came up to me and said
you want to share an apartment I'd of
course say no commitment girl we hate
that shit ooh punch testosterone balls
are seriously your stupid fucking movie
movie
you
what Victor finds out he's starting to
get some side effects as well I can't
pretend to know what we're dealing with
here we need to keep this confidential
Victor this disease is progressive
degenerative I have to notify someone
okay word of advice if you're talking to
a guy and he's stressed to go like this
he's probably gonna attack you or take a
piss probably both but they find out the
celebrity is apparently really tough to
get used to actually no they don't they
just wanted another reason for Alba to
strip naked doing this again I really
thought getting my skirt caught in
better luck Chuck will be the end of
these scenes are you gonna cure us I'm
gonna build a machine to recreate the
store jump wait a minute you can just
recreate the storm with a machine why
the fuck did you spend billions of
dollars to go into space that was it
like eggs versus egg beaters the
universe's version was just a little
more tasty sorry
it should we just put a counter there
yeah apparently that Phil needs it so
now again something you might have
noticed is really missing in this movie
is that there doesn't seem to be that
much crime fighting going up okay
don't get me wrong it's important to
understand your powers but in most films
it's like a few minutes tops we're an
hour in and all they've done is save a
bridge of people that really was caused
by them to begin with I'm not seeing
what's so especially fantastic about
them okay it looks like Johnny's finally
leaving
well good stop a robbery punch out a
crime boss or something Johnny Stone or
ride a motorcycle and whore yourself out
some more
it's what Superman would do oh yes he
did
so what are your superhero names they
call me the Human Torch and what about
the rest of the team that's the
Invisible Girl what about girl uh I'm 15
now miracle killed relatively pissed off
they go to confront Johnny about what
he's been doing
time to go street fighter bonus level
yeah yeah that would cut his head off
Brigid burn off fuck the block he
started it damn it Johnny ah now they're
supposed to be a crime-fighting in this
crime-fighting movie right hello hello
yes Ben ends up going to a bar where a
blind woman hears his woes and takes
pity on him there's a god it's me she is
not so into Hey look lady you can go got
a turn-up for all I care as long as you
convince somebody to start
crime-fighting but Victor vows to
destroy Reed I guess because he's more
successful and tries to turn the team
against each other what are you doing
here I was worried about you you know
for a guy who says he doesn't want to be
seen in public you should be seen in
public a lot Reed is gonna fix me up
okay I mean other
more time is soon what how dare that
asshole have a personal life I'm gonna
show him by refusing his cure no really
that's what happens I spent my whole
life protecting you and for what so you
could play twister with your girlfriend
while I'm the freaking away that'll show
my only hope for salvation I sure showed
me Papa Papa this should be turning me
on but the kind of is you two are on
your own
hey hey they'll go great with all the
black widow merchandise then leaves the
three of them behind to see if Von Doom
can help him out any better
his name is Von Doom do you want to be
Ben Grimm again just do it before I
remember whether or not I even run a
business anymore
Ben returns back to normal but Victor
feeds off the energy he emits to make
him even stronger he decides to give
himself a chilling identity one that
involves a creepy-ass mask given to him
for humanitarian purposes yeah I
remember when mother Teresa got awarded
a chain maize from India and decides to
go after Reed how by freezing him
apparently that's not like you after all
we're both doctors
I'll get it stop stop stop I just give
you a heads up guys
honestly I'm taking the corman version
more seriously than this I mean come on
what do you do did you raid George
Sanders makeup kit from the 60s Batman
you're two seconds away from the
Austrian ice puns let's check in on the
rest of the family let's do it before I
figure out why the hell I suddenly hate
you all right now Johnny distracts the
missile away while Susan goes to save
Reed fire
you know you really should be renamed
the mildly interfering for Betsy's the
trouble going on changes himself back
and very unrealistically gets over there
like the speed of fucking light it's
clobberin time that's what my toy sighs
damn I've been waiting to do that you
and abut numbingly bored audience buddy
so we finally get some real fighting
with powers rays electricity guys
getting hit by buses only to walk out
the door why is this a thing in bad
movies Johnny
supernova I thought we agreed that was
bad yeah risking the lives of all
humanity is worth it just to save our
selfish asses but it's contained in
Susan's forcefield and they end up
turning him into a real-life statue
resulting in the city throwing a big
boat party yes thank you for saving
yourselves as he was just basically
going after you the entire time
seriously Willis is playing again Sue
Storm will you marry me yes yes
that's my nose genius these are my lips
well mostly I've had them done like 10
times so I think you can see why as
superheroes we were so inspired by this
movie all you got to do is look hot in
tight outfits say a lot of exposition
about yourself without actually exposing
any character and only save people if
you yourself caused the trouble
those are the time just look out for
yourself and flaunt what little you do
sheesh
I can't imagine at all why anybody would
enjoy this fantastic superhero film it
just friggin his fires so much my god
guys Cthulhu is risen and he's taking
over the world netting fools I come for
your souls nah I think he'd be a good
ruler yeah everyone loves Cthulhu but
when he's done with the world he'll come
for you this looks like a job adequately
imprinted 3
what hell that was easy
what yeah Malcolm turned him into Xiao
Peng his head from Hong Kong 97
yeah stuck with the classics that's it I
want to expose myself to that meteorite
and actually use my powers to benefit
humanity
I'll write you giant sack of space rock
come to me wow you just became really
good at Hong Kong 97 how come you guys
get all the cool stuff because we love
you
it's clobberin time